18 décembre 94 dans les frimas d'une
campagne présidentielle amorcé les
pimentant le dal droit au logement 30
encore rue du dragon en plein coeur du
sixième arrondissement deux immeubles
vides sont occupés 130 personnes
prennent place dans des bâtiments
appartenant à la cogedim leproux est
classique mais l'avenir le dira bien
vite puis symbolique encore que les fois
précédentes
jacques chirac le futur est sommaire
joue la carte du candidat futur
président et lâche le mot clé
réquisitions j'ai engagé la procédure et
il faut maintenant qu où on décide que
c'est le berre et je procéderai aux
acquisitions ou qu'on décide que c'est
le préfet et qu'ils le fassent et le
préfet le fera en janvier 95 pour deux
immeubles de la capitale
le danemark le coup tu ton soulignant
l'insuffisance de l'initiative mais la
rue du dragon c'est aussi la naissance
d'une université populaire organisée
autour d'albert jacquard monseigneur
gaillot et léon schwartzenberg saint
janvier 95 des affrontements
manifestants forces de l'ordre marque
l'inauguration raté de l'association
droits devant
raison avancée par la préfecture des
paulistes souci de sécurité pour des
locaux inoccupés depuis longtemps
sécurité une spots ne pose plus aucun
problème mais ils l'utilisent comme
prétexte pour nous interdire vachard à
vii
le résultat c'est qu'on est dehors le
résultat c'est qu'on est beaucoup plus
nombreux et évidemment 5 95 des bus 96
des réquisitions initié par jacques
chirac après l'occupation du dragon font
leur chemin jusqu'au ministre du
logement pierre andré périssol il
annonce de plan d'urgence sur paris et
sa région de noël plus tard le 7 rue du
dragon va donc perdre ses célèbres
squatteurs certains roulent au géant à
chainel d'autres allant des logements
réquisitionné par le ministre le dal de
son côté peut fêter de cinq ans avec ce
succès là comme cadeau d'anniversaire